just heat it up at 300 and leave it in
for 35 minutes thanks Karen it's my take
on Mexican lasagna great Jeff and I
can't imagine what you're going through
well it's like if Jeff got hit by a car
and died suddenly and violently like
that well you get that dish back to me
whenever you can
welcome to friends at heaven
looks like we have so many people here
today I'm Judy Jones I hope this isn't
weird can I give you a hug
no okay I lost my fiance eight weeks ago
was really sudden had died
I got been sleeping not at all okay I'm
off all night feel free to call me we
can sleep together hey did you get it
say him no that's my other husband oh
and another one and you're fine you are
you in bed yeah what are you wearing
parents but this slower huh you're a
weird person
they do this a lot just every time I see
a person sized dent in the front bumper
of a car but it must be hard to be alone
in that big house without Steven my
guest house is open be nice having you
there boys
this is Judy hey yeah yeah yeah he
thinks that the bird this is that alert
maybe it is him yeah it's weird being in
there you don't even know her she could
be a crazy person who knows we're
looking for Judy hey why are you looking
for Judy let's just say that wherever
Judy domes chaos tends to 5
[Music]
because kind of game that you're playing
with there's a lot of [ __ ] you don't
know
brave doesn't hurt its people I know you
you're crazy I'm not
you invited a criminal into your home
she's the only person who's been here
for me that doesn't make me feel like I
am failing at everything I've got a
widow running around town like a white
wine magellanic haha
[ __ ] love you I miss you baby just
wanted to say that okay fine it's trying
a thing [ __ ] you too
[Music]
you